BlackRock CEO Larry Fink says Bitcoin
could revolutionize Finance
a lot of people start to ask themselves
why it is the CEO of BlackRock this
massive financial institution is all of
a sudden doing a turnaround and
supporting Bitcoin
that one's kind of concerning or I
should say disconcerting when there's
talk of the U.S losing its status as
Reserve currency especially over the
past several years and now more so with
brics Nations launching launching a gold
back currency the idea that this guy's
going to come out and be like I care
about people and I think you know they
should listen I don't know maybe I
shouldn't say anything Maybe not maybe
what happens is and again I don't know
I'm not a finance guy so don't take my
advice for it if the U.S loses its
status as the reserve currency War
breaks out the dollar is going to fall
to garbage you're not gonna you're not
going to be eating bread you're gonna be
eating bugs and living in a pod and
that's that's what I wonder about all
this when they say you will owe nothing
and you will be happy
maybe what they're not people think
they're saying they're going to take the
world from you maybe what they're really
saying is when the war happens you ain't
getting none of this stuff no matter
what you do the food's gonna be going to
the soldiers to the front line resource
and everything will be straight into war
and what will you have worthless green
pieces of paper to be honest digital
numbers on a computer screen we'll see
rationing all over again during the
second world war that was a reality
people could only consume so many
resources regardless of their level of
wealth because the government was saying
we need to use this rubber or fuel or
food for the war effort so let me ask
you guys what makes more sense
that powerful Elites in Europe and the
USA want you to eat bugs because of
their ideology or they were preparing
you for eating bugs because ain't gonna
be no food when War breaks out well I I
think it's a combination I think that if
your ideology is so corrupt and you hold
human life so cheap then it's inevitably
going to be the case you'll make the
sorts of Reckless decisions that will
result in your economy being destroyed
and people ended ending up being plunged
into Warfare which will destroy their
resources and lower their quality of
life I don't think that it needs to be
either or I mean yeah exactly I think
that there there are ample reasons for
ideologically possessed people that are
in positions of power to say look you
shouldn't be eating steak you shouldn't
be eating all this beef you should you
know and and red meat and stuff you
should be eating something that's
simpler and something that's better for
the planet because there are people that
truly believe that the that the the
world is overpopulated and that we need
to significantly decrease the number of
people on Earth because we keep
devouring the resources and we can't
produce enough uh resources and food to
sustain the population that we have and
while I don't believe that I do believe
that there are probably cons a
considerable number of people in
positions of power that are capable of
doing something about it uh and actually
affecting populations and and policy
that will
could or at least could significantly
lower the the population of the Earth
and I think that the the the the the the
global warming um alarmism that you see
is is the most likely method so things
like you know you can't have cows
because they are bad for the environment
and these bugs are better for the the
environment are are compelling arguments
to people that are already ideologically
kind of aligned or are used to getting
beat down with the the the world is
ending because of climate change kind of
thing so I don't think that it needs to
be one or the other I think that that
there are multiple reasons why people in
positions of power would want to say
look you you can't live the life that
you've been living and you need to roll
back your standard of living do you guys
remember that uh there was a document
that went viral from some security
contractor that claimed the U.S
population would be reduced by like 60
we talked about this I never remember
seeing that document because it was
erased from everywhere about based on
what though so there we don't know uh
some kind of Defense Contractor put
together a report talking about future
plans and it listed the populations of
many countries as having been reduced by
like 30 to 40 percent or something like
that or more and the document was
deleted I don't think we ever got a real
explanation for it I'm not saying it
means it's true if I I hate conspiracy
theories so you know for all we know uh
they were creating a hypothetical
scenario in the event of war or
something like that but then this this
uh the archives all got deleted and now
it's really hard to find any information
it is as if it has been erased from the
internet it makes you wonder about
what's really being talked about behind
the scenes because look froino Occam's
razor suggests this is just a nonsense
document some random guy said the
population would go down or something
like this but as we we see more and more
signs of major conflict escalating like
the clustering Munitions thing is a big
deal there's there's uh fears of the
zaprizia plant being blown up I believe
it's his operation one right that's
where they're saying that the Russians
have lined explosives around it or
something like that I don't know
I don't know you know you get propaganda
on both sides
and you got to figure out who you want
to trust but isn't it convenient for all
of us as Norma Donald pointed out that
uh the good guys won every war
keep that in mind as you as you consider
the news that's coming out today with
all of these uh major conflict stories
but also I think it's important to think
about
we I talked about this during covid uh
and I don't know if we were talking
about the context of War but what is the
one thing that is guaranteed that kova
did it got people to move out of cities
yeah it decentralized our economy
you add everybody working from the
office if that office got destroyed for
some reason let's say let's say
everybody's working at office and the
fire breaks down people get trapped
inside that company's gone
let's say you push everybody to a remote
work and get them out of cities that
office gets just caught in a fire your
company still exists digital economy
people are able to communicate
facilitate and keep working
so it made me wonder when we saw kovid
and the the main result was large Exodus
of major economic power from large
cities decentralizing this economy sure
was helping us prepare whether
intentionally or not for a major
conflict
if New York were to get nuked now our
economy would still function to a great
degree because many of these people who
run these systems have left and they've
spread out even so it's harder to Target
pre-covered with all of the big heads of
industry in San Francisco in California
in New York many in Chicago a single
nuclear weapon your economy is gone
postcovid not so much they're not going
to Target the CEOs and all these
different random places even celebrities
and actors are moving all over the place
they're not in the same place anymore
the people running these blue states are
secret Heroes they're trying to get
everybody out of the Cities Russia's
still I mean Russia still is the country
that has the most nuclear weapons in the
world are their nukes as powerful as
ours though like I don't know one I'm
not 100 sure I think they're more
powerful no
um but they they have the Satan too
tidal wave uh bomb or whatever it's
called yeah some of them uh in fact the
most powerful nuclear weapon ever built
was by the Soviets sorry about wow yep
okay and they only was it only ever use
it a quarter yield or something or half
half there's a hundred megatons was the
the design and they only used 50 I think
is the and the the bomber that dropped
it fell two kilometers from the sky in
the shock wave because it when then it
recovered oh my gosh yeah oh my gosh
yeah I was terrifying I mean imagine
what they have now I don't think it's
nuclear weapons I think they're well
they're Way Beyond this stuff I mean
we're talking about a weapon from years
ago a 100 year old bomb come on they got
something else already for sure yeah
anti-matter weapons how much you want to
bet they have anti-matter bombs well I
mean look we know that different
countries have been creating bio weapons
and we just know this because uh one was
released now Sir Francis Boyle uh who
was the author of the American
implementing legislation for the
bioweapons convention has stated as a
lawyer that these are if anything made
with gain of function research is
classified as a bio weapon so that's not
even like a conspiracy theory or a hot
take that is the author of the
legislation that governs these Affairs
specifically stating these are bio
weapons like anything made through gain
of function research and we know gain of
function research is happening so who
knows what's been created who knows the
kinds of ugly things that have been
engineered by uh scientists that could
be Unleashed onto the public at any
moment so we learned during covid that
Asians were more susceptible to the
virus because they have more ace2
receptors hmm think about something like
that we know that this particular group
of people has more of one type of
receptor in their lungs therefore they
may be more susceptible to a virus now
think about how they're going to make
bio weapons oh boy yeah they're going to
be like hey this particular group of
people susceptible to this particular
thing and then one day everyone in that
country is very sick that's bioweapons
and there will be collateral damage yeah
well no we also know like based on the
part of the world you're in and a lot of
genetic factors you can be more or less
susceptible to diseases this is the
entire point that gets brought up
anytime anyone wants to discuss like
colonization and the Conquistadors the
fact that the Spanish were totally
immune to the diseases they were
bringing over so they didn't even know
they had them someone could
theoretically engineer viruses and
disease that would be more likely to
wreak havoc on populations of different
people genetically that's terrifying I
always get real like and I don't know
how realistic this is because I have no
idea about how bugs are are engineered
or anything but the idea of Ebola with
like a three-week incubation period or
two week incubation period born Ebola
yeah just spreads around and it takes
weeks before you just start puking and
bleeding out your eyes and and with and
you're contagious the entire time that
the idea of that just terrifies the
absolute crap out of me because that
would run wild through through the whole
country and then you would have
basically everyone in this country
demanding lockdowns oh yeah oh yeah yeah
we did talk about this too I think you
know Ian asked the question when we were
like oh we're all against lockdowns he
was like What if it was an Airborne
Ebola and it's like that's a tough
question because now you're looking at
people puking up their organs and stuff
in the middle of the street but the
quest the issue is still you have a
right to choose if you want to take that
risk well but but there's there's
another Point here I think a lot of the
argument against like
vaccinations or forced vaccinations or
lockdowns or whatever it is they aren't
necessarily axiomatic arguments they're
questions of whether factors are such
that it justifies it so if you did have
an ebola if there was any bowl that had
like a 99 transmission rate and 99
mortality rate 100 you lock things down
except people trust to the government
yeah yeah exactly exactly but I'm saying
if that really is the case and you
really have those numbers of course
people are going to say yeah dude but
that's the thing it's it's not even
going to be a question because if you've
got if you've got like people like in
Mass just like puking and dying in the
streets and stuff like that people are
gonna voluntarily be like get the F out
of here get away from my house I'm not
going out it would be it would be a
lockdown that was completely voluntary
the police and I mean the only people
that would would be going to work would
be like doctors that actually could do
something and if if even because a lot
of times when you get to something if
you get to something that dramatic
there'd be a lot of people that are just
like staying home with my family yeah no
I I definitely agree with you it would
mostly be voluntary my point is simply
that when you get to a certain point of
transmission and mortality with the
disease lockdowns are going to be more
or less justifiable what will destroy
the world incubation period of two weeks
Airborne High mortality and a disease
that takes four to six weeks to kill you
so escalating degrees of severity uh
let's talk about the absolute you know
worst case scenario because if we're
talking about actual engineered bio
weapons these things are going to be
horrifying we're talking about a virus
that is Airborne
transmissible when a person is
asymptomatic couple weeks incubation
period High mortality rate
it would be impossible to stop unless
everyone locked their doors and no one
did anything ever again what are the
chances of a government actually trying
to build that virus I think 100 yeah
and we may have it now yeah they're not
you know gonna tell us what's going on
but why wouldn't they do it I mean look
at nuclear weapons they can wipe out a
whole city with with a single nerve
like I mean they can buy about multiple
cities with uh with a with a Merv 12
warheads and one ICBM I hate these
acronyms let's try this again 12
Warheads in one multiply a multiple
independently targeting re-entry
vehicles and uh in in uh that's what I'm
nerve is it's an intercontinental
ballistic missile you'd say like Merv
and ICBM and people like I have no idea
what you just said yeah I don't know man
it's tough are we sitting here spinning
our wheels and wasting our time argue
arguing about culture War nonsense no
when you when you go to the highest
limit no no when you go to the highest
levels and you see this is the case
let's let's talk about the realm of
domestic politics in this regard
if Donald Trump's world view is is
really let's not have the war that
destroys the planet let's Shore up our
borders protect the United States
bring back manufacturing and become
self-sufficient because the long fall is
coming
and the alternative is no let's go all
out take over the world and Destroy
Bricks by any means necessary so that we
can stay on top of the world which do
you choose
I think I think I think the Trump angle
is the is the is the better one well
absolutely and not just practically
speaking but morally speaking Not only
would that be there would be so much
Bloodshed and lost life if we tried
doing something like that but it yeah it
assumes it assumes that other nations
don't have the right to develop
currencies while we're debasing ours it
assumes that other nations should be
forced into dollar slavery and have to
hold this asset this currency while
we're abusing it and showing them we
don't respect it ourselves here's the
challenge
the Chinese Communist party is pretty
dang evil they are very evil absolutely
so there's the the other argument of if
we just decide you know what we're going
to close our doors to a great degree not
like like not completely but we're gonna
bolster the American economy and we're
gonna focus on ourselves China's Gonna
Keep expanding they're not going to stop
well it depends I mean firstly China
does get a lot of money from the United
States just with respect to the business
that we do with them so if we just
started doing everything domestically it
would be painful for us but I also think
it'd be very painful for them I'll also
add that if we were to go to war with
China over human rights abuses if there
was like a real legitimate reason for us
to go to war if you went through all the
tenants of just War Theory and they all
lined up then yeah that but that's a
different question than just going to
war with them over them wanting to use a
currency that isn't ours
okay the justification is a massive part
of it yeah yeah I think everyone was
just in agreement with you Sheamus good
good I like that perfect shimcast IRL
here we are there you go
I mean I don't know the the whole the
question is what does a regular family
do
uh-huh yeah well that I mean that's and
that's a very good question you've said
this on the show before uh but at the
risk of sounding like a broken record
I'll say it again for you I I believe
it's a good idea for people to get out
of blue areas generally speaking not
even necessarily because of this
question but just the fact that blue
States in blue Cities end up having
really bad policies they're gonna be a
lot of people there who are like not a
good influence for you and your family
so I'll put that out there and then you
know it's it's recommended by federal
agencies even in the United States that
you should have some emergency food
stored up I think people should do that
just try to live as moral a life as
possible people aren't going to be
surprised to hear this from me because
this is the advice I'm gonna give in
every situation but get close to Jesus
Christ really get right with God live a
moral life and then if something
horrible ends up happening if America
ends up being destroyed well you lived a
good life you did the right thing you
formed the proper relationship with the
truth thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time